Wenn wir heutzutage auf sozialen medien unterwegs
sind, sei es youtube instagram oder eigentlich egal
wo, da kann man schnell den Eindruck bekommen,
dass konsum der ultimative Weg zum Glück ist.
Von klein auf bringen uns die Gesellschaft und
große Unternehmen bei, dass Konsum etwas gutes
und untrennbar mit unserem Glück verbundenist und, dass wir nur genug arbeiten müssen
um uns diesen Lebensstil leisten zu können.
Aber was wenn die Gesellschaft falsch liegt
und das paradigma mehr Konsum bedeutet auch
mehr Glück nicht oder eingeschränkt wahr ist,
Wenn du sozialwissenschaften in der Schule hattest
dann sagte der name John Keynes vielleicht etwas,
Keynes war einer der bedeutendsten Ökonomen
des 20. Jahrhunderts und er hat unser
Verständnis von Wirtschaftspolitik grundlegend
verändert. Weitaus weniger bekannt ist Keynes
allerdings für eine andere Aussage. Im Jahr1930 prognostizierte er, dass wir durch das
fortschreitende Wirtschaftswachstum im Jahr 2030
nur noch 15 Stunden die Woche arbeiten würden.
Er ging davon aus, dass wir bis dahin so viel Geld
zur Verfügung hätten, dass der Hunger auf Konsum
gestillt sei und Freizeit einen immer größerenStellenwert einnehmen würde. Noch faszinierender
ist allerdings, dass Keynes die wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung der letzten 100 jahre dramatisch
unterschätzt hat. Wir sind heute noch viel reicherals Keynes damals voraussagte. Trotzdem sind wir
von der 15 Stunden-Woche noch weit entfernt. Wie
kann das sein? Wie konnte Keynes so falsch liegen?
Zu allererst ich bin kein Ökonom und ich kann
dir deswegen auch keine wirtschaftlich korrekte
Antwort auf die Frage geben. Ich glaube aber,
der Grund warum wir trotz unseres Fortschritts
immer noch so viel arbeiten lässt sich zumindest
unter anderem mit einem einfachen psychologischen
Konzept erklären der hedonistischen Adoption.
Die hedonistische Adaption geht davon aus, dass
jeder Mensch ein gewisses Grundlevel an Glücklichkeit hat.
Positive oder negative
Lebensereignisse wirken sich nur vorübergehendauf unser Glücksempfinden aus, denn mit der Zeit
gewöhnen wir uns üblicherweise an veränderte
Lebensumstände. Die hedonistische Adoption äußert
sich in allen Lebensbereichen. Trotzdem sticht das
Thema Geld und Konsum in meinen Augen besonders
hervor. Denn ich glaube Konsum ist etwas, an das wir
uns besonders gut gewöhnen können. Niemand würde
bestreiten, dass es ein kurzfristiges Glücksgefühl
auslöst, wenn man sich etwas neues kauft, aber du
weißt wahrscheinlich selbst, dass du dich über deiniPhone oder dein Auto nach einem Jahr nicht mehr
so freust, wie an dem Tag an dem es gekaufthast. Ich denke, dass dieser Gewöhnungseffekt
insbesondere dann problematisch ist, wenn es einemnach objektiven Maßstäben bereits sehr gut geht.
Da ich in einem der reichsten Länder der Welt lebe
ist meinen lebensstandard allein schon aufgrund
meines Geburtsortes sehr hoch. Ich musste mir noch
nie Gedanken über so einfache Dinge wie Essen,
Sicherheit oder ein Dach über dem kopf machen. Jede
Verbesserung in meinem Leben führt daher kaum noch
zu einer objektiv besseren Überlebenschance.
Gerade das ist aber der Maßstab, nachdem sich
unsere Gehirn oft immer noch richtet. Denn unsereVorfahren von vor tausenden von Jahren waren
praktisch nie in einer Situation, in der es von so
einfachen Dingen zu viel gab. Ganz im Gegenteil.
Es gab tendenziell von allem zu wenig. Deswegen hates sich evolutionär durchgesetzt, dass wir immer
mehr wollen. Und deswegen ist es auch so schwersich irgendwann mit seiner materiellen Situation
zufrieden zu geben. Davon abgesehen gibt es aber
noch einen weiteren Grund warum viel Konsum nicht
automatisch glücklicher macht. Es führt nämlichzu einem materialistischen Weltbild. In vielen
Studien wurde untersucht, wie sich Geld und Besitz
auf das Glücksempfinden von Menschen auswirken.
Eine der wichtigsten Erkenntnisse ist, dass die
absolute Menge an Geld ab einem gewissen
Niveau eine immer geringere Rolle spielt. Das heißt es
ist gar nicht so wichtig wie viel wir besitzen.
Viel relevanter ist wie wir unsere materielle
Situation im Vergleich zu anderen einordnen. Wenn
wir den eindruck haben, dass wir mehr besitzen
als die meisten um uns herum, dann macht uns das
tendenziell glücklicher. Das Problem ist allerdings
dass unser Umfeld kein korrektes Abbild der
Gesellschaft ist. Wenn du viel auf Instagram
unterwegs bist, wirst du wahrscheinlich den
EIndruck haben, dass gefühlt alle Menschen um mich
herum mehr besitzen als du. Du vergleichst dich
also regelmäßig auf einer materiellen Ebene. Damit
fördert du aber unterbewusst die Einstellung, dass
sich anhand von Besitz Glück festmachen lässt.
Wenn du zu den reichsten paar Prozent unserer
Gesellschaft gehört, dann mag das vielleicht
ein Ansatz sein der tatsächlich funktioniert.
Wenn du aber nicht dazu gehörst, dann tust du
dir keinen Gefallen damit dein Glück zu sehr
von materiellen Besitz abhängig zu machen. Denn
es wird immer Menschen geben die mehr besitzenals du.
In diesem Spiel gewinnen nur sehr wenige.
Ich denke wir sind uns aber einig ,dass nicht nur
diese Menschen ein Anrecht auf Glück haben, deshalb
ist ein erster Schritt materiellen Dingen nicht
zu viel Macht über das eigene leben zu geben.
Warum wir auf gesellschaftlicher Ebene dennoch
materiellen Dingen so viel wert beimessen hat
einen wesentlichen Grund. Unternehmen sind in einem
besonderen Maße auf die hedonistische Adaption
angewiesen. Denn es ist natürlich nicht gut fürs
Geschäft, wenn wir mit einem Produkt so glücklich
sind, dass wir nie wieder das Bedürfnis haben etwas
neues zu kaufen. Die hedonistische Adaption spielt
den Unternehmen daher in die Karten und weil sie
sich dessen absolut bewusst sind, fördern sie
durch viele Tricks den Gewöhnungseffekt.
Um wirklich glücklicher zu werden kann Konsum
nicht die Antwort, oder zumindest nicht die
einzige Antwort, sein. Stattdessen lohnt es sich
aus meiner Sicht den Fokus auf andere Dinge zu
richten. Solche die wir selbstbestimmter zu
unseren Gunsten beeinflussen können. Mit der
hedonistischen Adaption im Hinterkopf fallen
mir da zwei Ansätze ein. Zum einen die Frage
ob es nicht Dinge gibt, die zwei ein akutesGlücksgefühl auslösen, also ähnlich wie wenn
wir uns etwas kaufen, an die man sich aber nicht
so schnell gewöhnt. Und zum anderen fragt man sich
natürlich zwangsläufig, ob es nicht irgendetwas
gibt, dass das Grundlevel an Glücklichkeit
dauerhaft anheben kann. Und erfreulicherweise gibt
es aus meiner Sicht für beide Ansätze Antworten.
Anstatt sich ständig etwas neues zu kaufen ist, es
glaube ich viel besser regelmäßig neues zu erleben
und viel auszuprobieren. Denn neue Erlebnisse
sind etwas an das man sich per Definition noch
gar nicht gewöhnt haben kann. Je einzigartiger die
Erlebnisse sind, desto besser. Denn dann bleiben sie
uns einfach länger in Erinnerung. Egal ob du jetzt
anfängst ein neues Instrument zu lernen, das erste
mal alleine verreist oder einen anderen Weg zur
Arbeit fährst. Du wirst nicht nur länger glücklich
sein, sondern dich auch persönlich weiterentwickeln.
Mir ist es wichtig zu sagen, dass ich glaube, dass
man neue Eindrücke auf vielen verschiedenen Wegen
erreichen kann und auch schon kleine Dinge helfen.
Du brauchst nicht die Weltreise machen oder
Fallschirmspringen gehen. Auch wenn das natürlich
toll wäre. Ich habe zum Beispiel in den letzten
Jahren in meiner Freizeit praktisch nie gelesen,
weil ich durch das Studium schon so viel Zeit vor
Büchern verbracht habe. Ich wollte dann in meiner
Freizeit nicht noch Zeit von Büchern hocken. Jetzt
nach dem Studium habe ich wieder damit angefangen
und es macht mir richtig spaß. Das ist definitiv
keine große Veränderung, aber es hat ausgereicht
um mich glücklicher zu machen. Das ist also
durchaus eine Möglichkeit, die man auf viele Arten
in den Alltag integrieren kann. Es gibt aber noch
einen zweiten Aspekt der unser Glück nachhaltig
positiv beeinflussen kann. Einer der tatsächlich
wissenschaftlich nachgewiesen dazu in der Lage ist
unser Grundlevel an Gkücklichkeit dauerhaft zu
erhöhen. Die Universität Harvard hat sich die Frage
was ein glückliches Leben ausmacht nämlich bereits
1938 gestellt. Damals wurden über 700 Männer in
eine Studie eingeschlossen. Über die Jahre hinweg
wurden sie immer wieder zu ihren Lebensumständen
befragt, um Faktoren herauszufinden die ihr
Lebensglück beeinflussen. Das beeindruckende ist:
Die Studie läuft bis heute. Seit über 75 Jahrensammelt Harvard Daten darüber was diese Menschen
glücklich macht. Eine so lange Studiendauer ist
fast einmalig. Die Erkenntnisse sind unendlich
wertvoll. Über die Jahrzehnte konnten die forscher
eine Sache ausmachen. Eine Sache die durch alle
Schichten und alle Lebensumstände den wichtigsten
Einfluss auf das Glück dieser Menschen hatte:
gute Beziehungen. Wer in guten Beziehungen lebte, egal
ob mit Familie, Freunden oder in Gemeinschaften war
glücklicher, gesünder und lebte sogar mehrere Jahre
länger. Dabei zählt hier nicht die Menge sondern
die Qualität der Beziehungen. Das faszinierende
ist, dass die Qualität der Beziehungen ein
besserer Prädiktor für die Gesundheit im Alter
waren als der Cholesterinwert. Ein Wert der von
Ärztinnen und Ärzten standardmäßig genutzt wird,
um das Risiko für Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen
einzuschätzen. Der häufigsten Todesursache in
westlichen Industrienationen. Gute Beziehungen
sind also der Schlüssel zu einem glücklichen
Leben. Und das ist auch etwas an denen jeder
arbeiten kann. Welche Beziehungen wichtig sind
das kann jeder für sich selbst entscheiden. Ob
du ein Familienmensch bist oder Freunde die
Priorität haben ist egal. Wichtig ist, dass
du aktiv in gute Beziehungen investiert. Denn es
wird weitaus mehr zu seinem Lebensglück beitragen
als alles was du dir kaufen kannst. Konsum ist
ein integraler Bestandteil unseres Lebens und
ich glaube daran ist auch nicht schlecht. Das
Uiel sollte nicht sein kaufen als solches zu
verteufeln. Es geht eher darum das richtige Maß
zu finden. Oft wird weniger Konsum mit Verzicht
assoziiert, aber das ist meiner Meinung nach nicht
die richtige Sichtweise, denn man lässt ja nichts
weg was einen wirklich glücklich macht, Es geht
eher darum den Fokus zu verschieben und auf Dinge
zu lenken die ein wirklich glücklich machen. Ich
hoffe das Video hat hier auf irgendeine Art und
Weise geholfen. Ich tue mich selber noch oft damit
schwer weniger materialistisch zu denken, aber
ich glaube das ganze ist ein Prozess und es wird
wahrscheinlich niemals den Punkt geben an dem ich
mit 100%  Sicherheit sagen kann, dass
ich angekommen bin. Ich werde meine Gedanken zu dem
Thema aber auf jeden Fall auch in Zukunft hier
teilen. Wenn dich das interessiert dann abonniere
doch gerne meinen Kanal. Und wenn du noch weitere
Tipps hast, wie man der hedonistischen Adoption
entkommen kann, dann schreib sie gerne in die
Kommentare. Vielen dank fürs zuschauen. Bis dahin...